this metallica cd hasn't always been my
coffee coaster music used to come from
it and for 40 years this summer that's
been the case for hundreds of billions
of other compact disks cd sales actually
rose for the first time in nearly two
decades in the u.s last year sales of
vinyl and cassettes are up too so it's
worth asking on this the cd's 40th year
whether its glory days are exhausted or
if as many optimistic quadrigenarians
believe life only begins at 40.
cds were developed during the 1970s by
philips and sony and the first player
went on sale in japan on october the 1st
1982. the sony cdp 101 cost about a
thousand dollars equivalent to around
three thousand dollars today consumers
were told the convenience and sonic
prowess of the all digital cd made it a
no-brainer over bulky vinyl records or
fiddly cassette tapes and not just in
homes within two years sony had released
a portable cd player and another that
fit in cars adoption grew exponentially
in 1984 cds only accounted for about two
percent of recorded music sales in the
us by 1985 it was nine percent and by
1986 it was 20
but only parts of cd's magic had
actually been shown off at this point
consumers had no idea the technology
kept a massive secret
that was the fact that cds weren't
invented to just store audio not really
they were created to store binary data
which in the first instance were
digitized sound recordings behind the
scenes engineers were working out how to
format computer data for them
floppy disks at the time stored less
than about two megabytes of data while
cds could store hundreds
philips and sony have been working with
computing giants including apple and
microsoft and others and the first
computer cd-roms landed in 1986. cd-rom
quickly took off much like their sonic
brethren and much like the first iphone
cd's successful formula of simplicity
and adaptability looked to be
unstoppable
also like the iphone experiments with
how it could be exploited were routine
some failed out of the gate of course in
1991 philips released the cdi system
this 800 cd player plugged into
televisions rather than hi-fi's or pcs
and although it did play music it also
supported interactive video and even
games but cdi cost too much tried to do
too much and accomplished nothing very
well at all
sony succeeded here where philips had
failed by putting the technology into
something people already knew how to use
games consoles and in 1995 we got the
playstation it could even play audio cds
and in fact music for many playstation
games were stored on the discs as cd
audio files you could literally put them
in a hi-fi and play the soundtracks
there if you wanted
cds still hadn't shown off everything
they could offer in 1995 as well philip
said it had created specifications for a
rewritable disk aimed at the corporate
market it had already created blank cds
with sony that could be written to at
home using recordable hi-fi decks or
expensive computer drives
at the turn of the millennium there was
still little sign of cd slowing down
even as the internet took off in earnest
in homes and campuses and businesses
around the world
in the us in 2000 cds accounted for
close to 95 percent of all recorded
music sales however
nobody foresaw that cd had an achilles
heel students in campuses across the
world had learned about napster at the
turn of the millennium hence the famous
lawsuit with metallica here and we're
making bit perfect copies of each
other's music collections in a way
neither sony philips nor any other
company responsible for cds development
had anticipated before long the same was
happening with software infinitely
replicable with zero data loss something
that could have never happened with
vinyl or at the same scale with floppy
disks the lawsuits and plummeting sales
of recorded music that resulted from
napster and its copycats are well
documented but while the industry did
suffer enormously at the hands of piracy
it also forced the hand of innovation
and the result was itunes and then
spotify and you know the rest
so 40 years on is a slight uptick in cd
sales indicative of a revival of the
format i'm afraid to say almost
certainly not
at cd's peak they may not have offered
that collectible appeal and beauty of a
gatefold vinyl package but what it gave
in sound quality and convenience instead
was valued so much that it didn't matter
magnified by the adoption of cd-roms in
consoles and pcs the versatility of what
you could do with a cd and where you
could do it simply couldn't be competed
with
today that convenience and versatility
comes with the internet and apps while
vinyl which outsold cds last year is the
experiential collectible choice for many
people it's big it's pretty very easy to
autograph and lovely to put in a
collector's frame
it also still sounds amazing through the
right hardware and it doesn't have the
competition now that it had in the 1990s
that's why it's flourishing
the cd is a very special thing as game
changing as the iphone or even the web
in many ways but while it may be
enjoying a tiny flame with success on
its 40th birthday it's almost certainly
a last hurrah after a lifetime of
changing the world you may have your own
memories of cds or spiritual kin the
super audio cd or laserdisc or minidisc
find me on social media and let's chat
about those for quick take in london i'm
nate langston and i've been technically
speaking
[Music]